ich habe versucht die zahlen immer
zwischendurch zu verfolgen
allerdings haben wir irgendwann auch
schlafen gelegt weil das ja nicht
beeinflussbar ist von uns aus der wählen
die bürgerinnen und bürger amerikas und
das wird dann ausgezählt aber das ist
eigentlich die entscheidende aussage
jede stimme muss ausgezählt werden jede
stimme muss ihre gültigkeit haben das
gehört zur demokratie dazu
ich war das heute morgen im kabinett
kabinettssitzung mit der kanzlerin alle
minister sind zusammengekommen wie viele
waren übernächtigt wie viele haben durch
gemacht und wie nervös war man das ist
vielleicht doch donald trump werden
können ich habe mich heute sehr früh mit
meinen sozialdemokratischen kollegen
unterhalten dann allerdings habe ich
heute nun ausgerechnet nicht am kabinett
teilgenommen weil ich ja mit den
europäischen finanzministern den ganzen
tag über getagt habe und ein bisschen
dafür zu sorgen dass wir auch die
richtigen schritte wählen damit wir
durch die krise kommen aber sie stehen
ja in dauerkontakt mit der kanzlerin mit
den ministern wie war da so die stimmung
wie nervös war man auch ich meine sie
haben sicher festgelegt dass sie für joe
biden waren bei bild live vor ein paar
wochen vor ein paar monaten wenn jetzt
donald trump gewinnen würde was immer
noch möglich ist macht das die
zusammenarbeit ja nicht unbedingt
einfacher das ist sicher so wir mehr
erlebt was politische konzepte zuletzt
verfolgt worden sind aber ich will eine
sache ganz klar sagen wir müssen immer
mit denen regieren die in der welt im
amt sind
und natürlich ist es sache der
amerikanerinnen und amerikaner zu
entscheiden wer sie regieren soll
was wir hoffen und wünschen müsste es
zuallererst dass es faire und
demokratische wahlen sind und dass nicht
versucht wird das ergebnis zu
korrigieren wir sind bild und wie ihr
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren